ready I got seven bills not
eight one two
three four
five counted them wrong one two
three that's two
three you need the list to read off when
you do it no I'm looking at them now
seven you're right seven thank you can
you read it easily or do you want to see
this got them right here I know you do
but can you you where they are up tab
five 289 290 293 by representative
Edwards and 309 by representative F and
off of tab eight Senate once 291 and
okay you got it you got Jess and you 294
295 all
right all
right all right I'll call the uh fiscal
committee meeting to order for October
19th
2023 and uh mention that representative
Pearl will welcome representative Pearl
replacing Senator Senator Pearl
replacing Senator
bdel
and the first item on the agenda is the
acceptance of minutes some
move motion by Senator gray second by
Senator Rosenwald to accept the minutes
is there any further discussion seeing
none you ready for the question all in
favor say I I oppose no those are
adopted I'll abstain Mr chairman I was
not here one exstension two two two
obain two two exensions yes thank
you
okay all right right nothing on tab two
moving to tab
three see just about old business okay
old business for for the last two
meetings we uh we have asked for the
attorney general and the the
administrator of the fund to be here and
we they haven't come either time and
they said the first time that they did
they weren't prepared to come for and
they would be here this time I don't see
them here this time
we have been waiting for information
from them and we've been waiting for for
requests from them about changes that
legislation could be made to make to
make it more effective in terms of
dealing with the problem uh that's not
happened and uh that bothers me and uh
I'm I'm very concerned about that I'm
very concerned about the settlements I'm
very concerned about the people that are
involved uh and I and we've we've seen a
number of stories in the news about that
so I I want to voice my real concern
about the fact that nobody's coming
thank you Mr chairman and I have the
same concerns I'm told that they have
quarterly reporting requirements and the
quarter will be in November so they will
certainly appear
then they will be told that we're
waiting for these answers but it will be
a little late for doing any legislative
changes anything else under old
business then moving on the consent
calendar goes from tabs three through
8 or through nine and it go no through
tabs three through
eight these are the items that will be
removed by request from tab five
representative Edwards has requested
removing tabs 289 292
293 they are all dealing with HHS on a
common subject and representative F has
asked to
remove uh item
309 under Tab 8 the Senate has requested
removing
291 and representative Edwards and
representative F have requested removing
294 and 295 all of these items are under
the purview of the health and human
services department and they are here
but I wanted to give them warning but
those are the only items removed the
rest of the 26 items so there's 19 items
remaining on the consent
calendar I move the consent calendar
second Senator dallis Andro moves to
accept the rest of the items on the
consent calendar seconded by Senator
gray further discussion is there any
other the items that anyone wishes to
remove seeing none all in favor of that
motion say I I oppose no the rest of the
consent calendar is adopted we're moving
now to tab three and
items tab
five item 291 is the first one you come
to 289 I'm sorry got to read my own
notes
289 and
uh 289 290 293 all similar
topics and representative Edwards is
recognize to begin the question uh uh
thank you Mr chair um these three are
are bundled together um because they're
similar in many ways these are uh
federal funds the state is accepting to
to uh assist with uh a refugee program
um my my my uh thoughts around this are
that
um in the last couple years we've had
7.5 million people come across the
southern border that's five times the
state of New Hampshire uh many of them
have been going to Massachusetts uh the
governor there has declared that their
housing stock uh is overwhelmed and they
may no longer be able to um support
their law that says that everyone shall
be
homed uh and as a result I'm I I think
it's just reasonable given the proximity
for us to begin
anticipating what's going to happen if
uh if uh New Hampshire starts to get a
significant number of U of refugees and
so I'm I'm really asking
uh a question of the department about
the extent to which we are engaged uh
with um uh I I don't know if it's
Homeland Security I'm not sure which
federal agency is managing uh the inflow
of of uh the 7.5 million people but um I
I uh could you could you talk to us
about what you perceive the risk is I
use risk not as a threatening term but
just as a management term you know
looking at things that may affect us
could you could you tell us what sort of
thought process is being put into um how
many new people may be showing up within
the state of New Hampshire in the coming
budget year budget cycle till June of 25
and uh what sort of thought is being put
into it now in terms of um what sort of
demand it'll put on General funds or
given our Workforce shortages what it
may mean to our ability to support U New
Hampshire uh
citizens good morning Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer I I I think to start I
don't know if we came prepared to answer
such an expansive question um because
that has many uh assumptions unknowns
and demographic indicators that I don't
necessarily have available with me today
um I I can I can hand it over to uh
Ruben Hampton who is the office of
Health Equity director to provide
insight into the specifics of these
items but I I don't know representative
Edwards if I can really give uh a a a
cogent answer precisely without doing a
fair amount of research and response to
that
question uh so this is similar to the
questions I had asked during the budget
process with the standard house budget
process and so I don't I don't think I'm
laying a surprise on you that I have a
continued interest given that the issue
is is just continuing to uh expand in
its potential impact on the state uh I I
I just don't want to be standing here in
six months to nine
months uh with a with an enormous Bill
put on us and um and and and and to have
an
exacerbation Workforce shortages and
housing shortages and the like I'm just
not I I I just would like us to get
ahead and anticipate the chaos that
could could come from enormous numbers
moving into the state so um so if
there's not an answer
today uh I I will have a continuing
interest in this and let's continue to
have the conversation because you know
no no surprise is a good surprise in
this case and and I'd love to hear from
uh your last name or first name is
Ruben yes good morning uh Ruben Hampton
director of The Office of Health
Equity I think I remember meeting you
when you were first brand new right and
it's it's been almost a year now about
nine months yes we met at the budget
hearing great what do you have to share
with us so uh representative Edwards the
refugee program uh serves those who have
are or our eligible population so it
would not be any of those folks who you
know would come over it would be all
those who had been vetted prior to
entering the United States right they
would have been granted this status
prior and it is only a you know a select
few so I think I like that answer but
just to really pin it down to make sure
I understand it those people are coming
across the border and claiming Asylum
are they categorized also as
refugees so they are not
refugees those who have been granted
Asylum would be ases and would be
considered an O eligible population but
they would have to have been granted
Asylum if they sought Asylum and not
been granted it they are not considered
or eligible and they would not be served
by this
program okay so just to nail it um so in
these two or these three requests for um
accepting of federal funds these are
these programs are are not really open
to those who have filed an asylum claim
but have not yet been adjudicated they
are not eligible for these programs they
are not eligible and some of these funds
are for specific populations that
wouldn't be for those folks anyway like
some of these funds are for those who
are you know Ukrainian right and other
specific popul populations but yes to
your point representative Edwards if
they have not been approved for Asylum
they would not be an O eligible
population it would not be eligible for
uh the benefits that that's outstanding
situational awareness that calms my
fears about a flood that we can't afford
so thank
you Mo the item
second do want to move all three
Senator gray um that's my question I
think that since they were on the
consent since we've taken them you know
the testimony individually if the chair
will allow I will move all three of them
89 uh 29 289 290 and 293 second and a
second motion and a second Senator gray
and Senator rosenal further discussion
on these we'll be ready next time with
with more answers uh all in favor say I
I oppose no the motion is adopted the
next one I have on removal is uh item
23309 uh representative F has
questions
all right first we represent we'll
recognize representative Edwards for a
question all right uh thank you Mr chair
um the my question about this is that we
have a rebalancing demonstration program
and it says very specifically in the
final sentence that if federal funds no
longer are available General funds will
not be requested
and I always wonder about these if if if
if this is likely to be a successful
demo uh what would we do would are we
really prepared to wrap it up and shut
it down if it's successful or might it
find its way into a future budget I I I
just want to make sure I'm clear on
whether or not we we say this out of
habit or if we really mean it are we
really not going to ask for General
funds um good morning I'm Melissa Hardy
I'm the division director for long-term
supports and services thank you
representative adward for the question
um you know I think from a I can talk
from the programmatic standpoint we've
had a program like this in New Hampshire
before um probably six or seven years
ago called Community passport program um
what we anticipate is that the federal
government will continue to fund money
falls the person there hasn't been any
indication um that this will not be
funded through the feds um and since it
has been an ongoing historic program
that they have funded um if if it is
something that's successful that keeps
individuals and uh into the community
rather than in in institutional care I
think we would certainly have a
conversation about how um if the federal
funds stop how we would um have a cost
Savings in New Hampshire and looking
into budgeting that but but at this
point in time it's our understanding
that those federal funds would continue
to come which is why we included that
statement that's that statement is based
on the best possible knowledge that we
have available
today thank you Mr chair I I I I just
being a purist it sounds like we're not
really saying General funds will not be
requested we're saying that at this time
no General funds are anticipated to be
requested and and I don't know if this
language is just boilerplate or or in
law or something but I I just like
Clarity because these documents speak to
the public as well I just want to make
sure the state is saying what it really
thinks I think for this particular item
we um are assured through the Feds that
we will get this amount so what we're
requesting um will be federally funded
um beyond that I I think that would be
up to
discussion representative f for a
question uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking the questions I actually
have two questions if that's okay okay
what are the historically underserved
communities requiring Equitable
Care thank you um we had to identify
that in our application for money falls
the person uh based on some CMS
guidelines that we had so that typically
includes um individuals in rural
communities who have um access concerns
to Services just due to um their
geographic location also folks that may
have some language barriers um in
accessing or applying for uh benefits
through the Money Follows the person
program it could be perhaps folks from
diverse backgrounds that uh may not be
familiar with what's available out for
Service delivery and also folks who
struggle maybe just accessing um the
system itself so it could be folks who
don't have internet access or
Transportation barriers to actually
apply for services thank you followup
followup so separate question not really
a followup um when will the system
assessment and GAP analysis start
becoming available and where could we
find it when it does yes so we're
currently working with a stakeholder
group um we did um we are Contracting
with a provider to work with that group
um the timing of that I don't know if I
have that right in front of me
um I will have to get that too I don't
have that timing in front of me but I
can do that we're currently working on
that with our stakeholders thank you
senator rosenal for a
question thank you Mr chairman good
morning I understand that this is going
to be somewhat different from the
community passport program but my
question is how are you going to define
success this time sure what is it look
like is it saving money because
somebody's not in a nursing home or is
it
individual satisfaction or ability
to get the services
they're uh prove for or sure I think I
think you hit I think you hit it on the
head on a couple of those areas so part
of the mfp program is doing satisfaction
surveys which we historically um have
not done um on the Aging side of of our
business so that's part of this program
passport which is the previous iteration
of money follows a person really focused
on transitioning folks out of nursing
homes into the community and for this
program we're really looking at how
we're keeping people into the in the
community versus um them going into
institutional care so it's kind of a
little bit of a swap of thinking and
taking PE from before from taking people
out of the nursing home into the
community but now we're really looking
to strengthen the community service to
keep people in the community so I think
those are a couple of our measures as
you as you
mentioned the question thank you so
we're uh we have an informational item
before us today on the Medicaid rate
increases and my understanding is the
CFI rates are going to go up about
30% won't that by itself go a long way
towards guaranteeing that the workforce
and therefore the
services are available what what else
are you looking to do yeah sure I think
I think that certainly is a is a large
help on the CFI Community but there's a
lot of people living in the community
that cannot access access CFI whether
that's because they don't meet um the
medical level of care or they don't meet
the Medicaid level of care to um get
waiver services so there's some there's
a population of folks in the community
that receive services such as meals
transportation that are not that is not
funded by Medicaid um so we're they're
funded by their Grant programs um so we
certainly um appreciate um the historic
budget that was passed and um we know
our stakeholders are certainly um very
excited on the CFI uh rate increases but
there are also folks that can't access
CFI just either because of their
financial status or their medical
status further questions from committee
members saying none I'll entertain a
motion
motion and a second to adopt the item
any further discussion seeing none all
in favor say I I oppos no that item is
adopted okay moving on to tab
eight I'll recognize uh somebody from
the senate for item 23
Senator
rosenal thank
you thank you Mr chairman I just um from
The Narrative did not understand what
this item was
doing you want to open
it so um I'll speak to the the financial
side of it and then I will hand it over
to Melissa to speak to the programmatic
aspect um there there's there's two
technical requested actions here one is
transferring funds um and you will see
that transfer where we're moving it from
the payments to Providers to the
contract line into 102 and the reason
that we're doing that is because there's
been changes in the plan and um the
other aspect of this is the acceptance
of the of the enhanced uh dollars into
the budget this year um as many of you
may recall we did not include many of
the federal pandemic uh any of the
federal pandemic doar in the state
budget we've already accepted various
arpa funds earlier I think it was in
June um where the fiscal committee
accepted those funds and that's why
you're seeing that acceptance being
brought here now um and I will hand it
over to Melissa to speak to the program
yes so as we do our quarterly reporting
to CMS on our spending plan um as Nathan
mentioned we're able to refine some of
the financial aspects so moving those
dollars into contracts so over the past
quarter we've been able to fund some
contracts um that have been approved
through GNC such as um you know 111 beds
for folks with intensive treatment
service needs to uh buy property or
refurbish property so they can live into
the community um also we've uh been able
to uh uh award 27 grants as far as uh
Workforce retention and recruitment so
about $16.3 million to Home and
Community Based providers for uh
Workforce and recruitment strategies has
not been yet approved by GNC but we are
currently in the um final stages of that
RGA process so um it it's fluid every
quarter as we give our um update to CMS
as far as how we are able to contract
out the dollars for our Arbor spending
plan further question thank you just a
quick followup so we've lapsed some of
this additional F FMA over the last
couple of years are we actually going to
spend this money we're not not going to
lapse
it um I I I do know that the team is
working diligently to move forward um
you know oftentimes we do have
challenges with Contracting sometimes
our contracts don't get through
sometimes they get tabled and voted down
which just happened yesterday um for one
of our items so we work as hard as we
can to get these dollars out the door as
part of the pro as part of the plan that
Melissa's teams work with CMS um we
don't intend to to have any dollars laps
but sometimes there are variables that
are outside of our control thank you of
course Senator Pearl for a
question thank you is any of this money
being spent to alleviate the situation
that's going on in our Hospitals now
where we've got essentially long-term
care patients that are stuck there
because they can't get placements
anywhere
else I would say that you know all of
this all of these funds are focused on
Home and Community Based Services and
that's certainly um a population of
folks that we know um whether they could
get um Services through CFI or other
Home and Community Based access services
that that would help that flow from the
hospital either back into the community
um we know that our community based
providers are struggling with Staffing
and that sometimes is a reason why we
cannot coordinate services from the
hospital to the community so we feel
that these dollars since they are um
communitybased focused will help um some
of that boarding in hospitals um we also
know um you know Staffing and nursing
homes is is is tough as well so some
people um as Staffing changes in nursing
homes um you know that helps move people
out of the hospital and step them down
into that level of care although nursing
homes aren't covered um in in this uh
ARA spending because they're not
considered Home and Community Based
thank
you representative f for a question uh
thank you Mr chair I just want to
confirm something I think I heard I may
have heard it wrong um first of all I
was was told this was a 10% fmap um as
opposed to the sort of standard 6 and a
half% and then was something you
actually had to apply for to get as
opposed to the other fmap stuff which
was sort of Auto just coming on is that
is that am I did I misunderstand those
points you're referring to the enhanced
6.2% I'm sorry versus yes versus this
one involved in the initial application
director liman has some input we put the
tables down there so we don't have to
play music chair
yeah director if you want to sit at one
of those those side chairs and use one
of those
mics director Lipman has something to
add thank you for the question
representative or if you're correct this
was the 10% and we did have to um
demonstrate uh that as uh Melissa was
saying there C only certain Services
were qualifi for the 10% and so we had
to put together a plan as well as a of
what we wanted to do we also had a
develop a methodology for claiming that
had to be approved it was a multi-step
process versus the 6.2% that you're more
familiar with was sort of automatic
um thank you very much you're
welcome Senator Bradley for a question
uh thank you very much good morning so
how does this funding intersect with
what we did in the budget in
particular uh the Senate Bill 36
provision for uh long-term
care so I would say um for for this arpa
funding it it's a separate funding
stream than what was uh approved for 30
for Senate Bill 36 but um certainly they
intersect with each other as it both are
focused on keeping folks into the in the
community
um so there are some places where it
will overlap as far as I think
especially the recruiting and retention
dollars um to help support that system
of care for healthy
aging and these yeah thank you Mr chair
sorry um these funds would
um not be able to be used
for uh raate increases for providers is
that correct it's just for the four
things
outlined that is correct yes
okay okay thank you director Lipman
anything to
add no I'm I'm all set thank
you second okay motion to accept item
291 by
um Senator rosenal second by Senator
Bradley is there any further discussion
on the item seeing none you're ready for
the question all in favor say I I no
that item is adopted moving on to items
294 and
295 taken together that they're both
about
vaccines and I
guess Senator Edwards and Senator F both
have questions on those who's ready
first Senator Edwards representative
Edwards uh representative Edwards yes
sir thank you U Mr chair I um
I I have had an ongoing concern about uh
the acceptance of of money and the
expenditure of money to have the state
basically put in a position where it
appears as though uh we are certifying
or
endorsing um childhood vaccinations of
the coid
vac and uh I
I would like to know um to what extent
you think
294 and and maybe
295 are going to end up spending money
to try to Market or make available the
coid shot to healthy children under the
age of
18 sure good morning uh so my name is
Ryan tanion I'm the bureau chief of the
Bureau of infectious disease control I
don't know I don't know we've ever met
are you new uh I've been in my role for
uh effectively 11 months I was there
previously in an acting position okay
well welcome thanks excellent thank you
um so both 294 and
295 um yes they do support both the
bridge Access program which is specific
to adults and Co 19 vaccine the and then
our vaccines for children program but
this is more for internal operations to
the program um not so much just the co
vaccine followup thank you Mr chair so
um so this is internal operations this
isn't any sort of shots on Wheels
getting it out to the public or schools
this is all just basically uh
administrative management within the
department uh in infrastructure uh
technology and then um uh yeah
operational uh cost so the uh the
sources from the federal government on
this actually prohibits us from doing
direct purchase of vaccine so we
wouldn't be purchasing any vaccines with
these funds and final followup followup
okay are you are you a physician or
clinician yeah I'm a registered
pharmacist in Hampshire so uh are you
aware of any sort of definitive set of
clinical studies that have determined
the efficacy and safety of the coid shot
for otherwise healthy children under the
age of
18 uh
so you know I do have some uh other
information that I'd be happy to share I
work closely with uh our state
epidemiologist Dr Benjamin Chan on this
um you know as we know with any vaccine
whether it's flu or pneumonia there are
ongoing studies to look at advocacy U
you know so most related probably to the
flu we know each year that um the E
efficacy so I'm specifically interested
in Co and so it's kind of yes or no you
you are aware or you are not aware of
any good set of clinical studies to
indicate the safety and efficacy of the
coid shot for children under the age of
18 representative Edwards I believe we
had provided um Dr Chin had provided an
item with a write up of the various
studies on this topic I I I can see if I
can dig into it uh it probably was last
year I think we had provided some kind
of write up where we included like 100
different studies or something like that
on this question so so my question I
think got it buried in the Avalanche of
studies I just would like the very
specific studies related to safety and
efficacy under the age of 18 period sure
yep so Dr Chan had provided that science
brief uh as uh Mr did have another
person that wishes to comment and
identify yourself
first hey good morning uh my name is Ian
wad I'm the deputy director for public
health so as Nathan mentioned we did
provide a number of scientific studies
um provided both by by academics as well
as uh Federal and and state resources be
more than happy to provide those uh
again to to the uh the fiscal committee
uh I would focus the question that you
know ultimately our our vaccine for
children program and the state will only
provide uh vaccines and and support
vaccines that are federally approved
that have been approved uh through
various scientific boards as well as
medical boards um and we that has been
our Legacy policy that continues to be
our policy to approve things that have
been scientifically approved uh and the
co vaccine does does qualify under those
criteria all right so I understand that
there are boards that are positioned to
be viewed as SCI ific boards but I'm not
convinced that they've been following
the science in terms of making sure that
these Pro these vaccines are safe and
efficacious for this particular
demographic and I'm concerned that we're
not doing a very good job of advertising
the risks associated with it and the
unknown part of of the long-term effects
of it so so so so please don't give me
exactly what was given by Dr Chen last
time I'm very specific around studies
that demonstrate the efficacy and safety
under the age of 18 and so maybe there
are new studies because it's been nine
months since I last asked but um so so
thank you I just really think it's
important that we protect our children
and and I'm not sure that this program
the coid vaccines really do so and
critical to the conversation we have
around vaccine in the department is the
conversation between an individual
parents uh and children and their PCP so
certainly we require that the people
consult with their primary care
physician who are evaluating individuals
individual circumstances and any
concerns of parents they may have and
certainly rely on the the medical
community and providers to be well
informed and and have a dynamic
conversation with their patients about
what's what's needed and and required
representative f for a question uh thank
you Mr chair actually my question is not
related to these two fiscal notes but it
is related to vaccines um the co vaccine
in particular you've probably seen in
the news I hope I have that nursing
homes are having a difficult time
getting the co 19 vaccine and yet it is
generally available in pharmacies for
non nsing home populations and the
federal government apparently there
something to do with that I'm just
wondering is there anything the state
can do that can uh help with that
problem another person that wants to
have
input sure yeah so as we know uh the co
19 vaccines have since been
commercialized um so that has kind of um
changed or reverted back to the normal
supply chain process for healthcare
providers including long-term care
facilities to acquire the vaccine um and
you know we have been seeing that in the
news and we're soliciting feedback from
uh providers and long-term care
facilities to see what any type of
support that we may be able to help them
with so you are looking into and trying
to help them out is that what you're is
that the bottom line of what you just
said the
okay thank
you I move item 294 and
295 okay Senator gray moves the two
items and Senator rosenal seconds before
we leave it I have one more question I
want to be reassured on the record that
these shots will not be forced on our
children by putting them in the required
list of shots before they can enter
school that's correct um we've provided
uh testimony for a number of pieces of
legislation staying that we do not um we
are not at all looking to add the co 19
vaccine to the school or Child Care
requirements thank you further
discussion on this item seeing none
ready for the question all in favor say
I I oppose no no okay you wish to be
recorded all right two items are adopted
with one negative vote now moving on to
tab nine the regular calendar
the item is
23315 from the Department of
Transportation there questions on the
item from committee
members a motion to move the item by
representative leean second by Senator
dallesandro is there any further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no thank you who mov
okay moving on to item I guess that was
the last one but we have some
miscellaneous items that may have there
may be questions
on um I believe we have one on
23280 Administrative Office of the
Courts
someone indicated there would be a
question now I don't remember who was it
rep representative Edwards I my only
note to myself is I have a a question
about 312 on the informational materials
I don't have any until
then okay these are just information we
don't need any uh any motion to accept
them Senator rosenal I also had a
question on the HHS
dashboard which is
36 so I guess we're back to thank you
very much I thought we had a question on
that one I had a note there when we had
earlier discussions so we're back to
health and human
services and I see item
23311 I had a note that represent Earth
had a question J the Das before before
that's the dashboard which one 306 306
we go to 306 first and Senator rosenell
has a question on thank you
um just my questions have to do with
what is going on at Hampstead
Hospital uh there was just an article in
the nashwa telegraph this morning that
the police Le local and state have been
called 130 times in the
last little bit over a year for issues
ranging from physical assault to sexual
assault and that the their are questions
about the contractor we had been told
back in when did we visit Hamstead as a
committee May June
April that the contract was abouted to
be rebid but now it looks like it hasn't
been yet I know the department has
changed the management team which is the
only state employees but they're not the
ones who are
providing clinical
or other Direct Services to children and
I see that despite the promises of
wellpath to increase the number of beds
we still where we were when we bought
the place so I'm hoping that you have
news for us on how we're going to
make Care at Hamstead more
available and
safer and better sure thank you so
probably not a question for Nathan I I I
can provide some detail though on on the
contract in the RFP Ju Just to start so
so we had gone out to bid for that
contract which expires in June um and we
ended up cancelling that and I'm not
disclosed as to say why there's a state
law that actually prohibits it um but we
are going to be reposting that here in
the next month so expect to see a new
RFP posted in November on that topic um
and do you want to take it
hi good morning an leandry associate
commissioner um thank you so much for
your question and your concern and I
honestly wish I had more information for
you today than was shared yesterday at
the council meeting and unfortunately
commissioner weer and Associate
commissioner hen who are very involved
um with Hamstead and the the leadership
there are were unable to make t meeting
but I can say that we have as department
has been actively actively in involved
since the purchase of Hamstead and with
the leadership in place um we understand
there has been some challenges over the
summer we've acted quickly we have made
leadership changes there and that goal
of that leadership is to work hand inand
with the leadership of the contractor
and to be more collaborative in and to
ensure that we have our pulse and
everything that's going on um we've been
working actively with the local Town
Municipal and law enforcement as well as
the state police and our interventions
have um have equated to a decrease in in
um in calls to the the local Hamstead
police and so is top of mine and we are
there every day working on it and so I'm
H I'd be happy to have commissioner
weaver or associate um excuse me Deputy
Commissioner H now as of yesterday um
reach out and schedule some time with
this group to talk more at
depth further question you I mean
reading that the police are physically
restraining children so they can be
medicated into submission this is a
hospital and I it is really concerning I
think probably not just to me but it's
certainly really concerning to me I want
Hamstead to be
successful
and we have not been
told that we haven't given the
department the resources they need to
make it successful if there is
something that the department needs to
make it successful I hope you will tell
us because this is really
concerning thank you thank
you dalland thank you Mr just to follow
up you know first of all we don't have
enough Troopers to cover the roads so
when you tell me that we need Troopers
to go to himad that's highly problematic
we got 70 plus vacancies as far as state
troopers are concerned so we don't have
the people that's number one and if the
local community's law enforcement is
being called upon they have to get
themselves out of other items to address
these situations we spent a lot of money
to get the hospital we spent 13 millions
of American Recovery money to buy the
facility because the facility was going
to take the place of what we were doing
in the past at New Hampshire hospital
all right so we close those beds we move
them over here we were supposed to be
able
to take care of the Deeds of these
children we visited the place and we saw
what was going on at the place and we
saw the restrictions in terms of the
usage of space there was a lot of space
that wasn't used because we didn't we
couldn't get people so just following up
with what Senator Rosell said if you
can't get the people and you need more
resources there's a place to
come but we are being uh affected by the
newspaper articles people call us and
say what the heck is going on here and
and U the newspaper articles sometimes
they overblown you what's what's the
real truth and that's that's the real
issue but the Public's perception that
we're not doing the job and the fact
that we have these huge lapses from HHS
because we don't spend the money that
we've allocated that's very very
concerning to me very concerning to me
but you can lapse a hundred million doll
that's a that's a significant problem we
all say gez we don't have enough money
well we don't have enough money we're
lapsing it and that money where's that
money where the laps is going they're
going into the Revue stabilization fund
so we're building that up and at the
same time we're not answering the
needs this is look at this is something
that really really concerns me I've
dealt with kids all of all of my life
and uh I I remember what we used to do
here and we've made dramatic
changes but this kind of stuff is very
disconcerting thank you Mr chairman
thank
you
comment
I I would just say thank you for your
comments and concern and I I just want
to assure you that we all have a shared
interest and goal in here in keeping our
children safe in the state and we're
doing everything that we can and we can
certainly have folks follow up on the
specifics of of whether we need
additional resources or not at a later
date but we are we have a shared
understanding and goal
here representative Edwards uh thank
thank you Mr chair uh just for the good
of the fiscal Comm committee um Senator
birdell uh has been leading U uh impacts
assessment committee taking a look at
the impacts of the sununu center and
rather than just uh narrowing our focus
on the the new addition of the cunu
center uh she took it upon the committee
to take a look at the entire effect of
the existing Legacy hosp hospital and
the and the and the challenges that have
been there um and there's a sub a
subcommittee chaired by um U Mi uh Mr
Edwards Eddie Edwards looking
specifically at the security issues and
I know that he's in a final drafting
stage of a report that may address many
of your questions Senator um and and
attendant with all of that is a public
Communications effort um that's uh that
the committee is trying to execute I
don't know the details because I've been
in my house for two months but but I
know that they're working
it thank you further comments from the
committee on the
items representative
Lehman thank you Mr chairman so a number
of us have been sitting around the table
and dealing with a cunu nightmare and
this appears to be another nightmare
here and the making and not to put
either one of you on the spot but you
haven't really said what is going on
what's caused the problems that
represent uh Senator rosenal mentioned
in the article why haven't we been made
aware of it uh why is the Press hearing
about it before we are so what is going
on over
there hi thank you for your question um
I can't speak to to the timeline of
communication
around the events at Hamstead or or or
how this group is traditionally informed
on on these events um I can I can just
say that based on based on the events
that have happened and some of the
security security challenges and risk
we've we've done everything we can to
ensure that their security staff is
fully um staffed I believe as of this
week correct um they are and that
there's been changes in leadership to
ensure that that the situations that
have happened over the summer do not
happen um again and that we're doing
everything we can to keep the kids safe
as well as um you know get to capacity
as soon as we can so as Nathan mentioned
the RFP is being re-released um to look
at the contractor and I know it's not a
perfect answer um again commissioner
Weaver and Deputy Commissioner hen
likely have more information more
specific specifics to share with you
which I'm sure they'd be happy to follow
up Unfortunately they weren't able to
come today but I don't want to misspeak
as I don't have all of the answers to
your questions
today follow
up so again this is offered in the
spirit of uh help helping the fiscal
committee um in in HHS oversight as well
as the sununu impact committee this very
issue has come up what what happened we
we we we bought Hamstead it had a stable
state it didn't have all these problems
now it does what changed and the
response that we got back I think on a
on the record somewhere is that um the
uh patient Acuity at Hamstead was not as
high as the state changed it to being
and as a result some kids got brought
into Hamstead under sort of a new scheme
of of allowing more difficult Acuity and
that the Hamstead had not been designed
to have secure features like doors in
the hallways that shut they didn't have
the security staff basically it was a
little bit more of a surprise than I
think it should have and so they there
was this huge problem and I I would
imagine if we were to look at the stats
I I got to believe that the number of
incidences and calls to the the police
has has been declining precipitously is
is my theory but um but so that's what I
know about it all
right anything
further all right seeing none we don't
need a motion on this but I also had
questions on information items 23 311
and 312 that somewhat related um again
HHS I guess rep representative Earth had
questions on
2311 so thank you for taking the
questions I have five questions they're
fairly broad maybe even extremely broad
so I'm not expecting to be able to
answer them now but if you can at least
um take take note of them and U maybe
provide written responses I'd really
appreciate it so this is regarding the
annual report on the medicad expansion
program if I'm not
mistaken and if I just Mr chair is I
just rattle through the five give them
time to in between to respond if they
want to yes okay so the first and Al
I'll just PA between them if you want to
respond that's great if you don't just
say you don't so describe quote the
funding of the nonfederal share
to include this is a quote from the uh
fiscal note the funding of the
non-federal share to include profits
from The Liquor Commission through the
alcohol prevention and treatment fund
and here's the really critical part and
limited the New Hampshire Health Plan
assessment to no more than the funding
needed to cover the remainder amount not
to exceed the monies from insurance
premium tax revenue and alcohol
prevention and treatment fund as well as
other funds returnable and I I know
that's related to hb4 from 2019 um if
you want to respond now or
later I think I can help and if um my
answer is not enough I'd be happy to as
you requested put something in writing
so in terms of the granted Advantage
Program the federal match is 90% Federal
10% um other funds the other funds are
comprised of uh
three things um primarily uh the the
first one would be the premium tax which
is a standard tax applied to all health
insurance policies of 2% on the the
policies that are ungranted
Advantage the the liquor um profits that
there's a uh that there's a specific
percentage there that's run about 10
million or so a year um in 200 I think
uh 18 or or 19 um the New Hampshire
Health Plan um is also assessed an
amount and the the amount that's
assessed is to make up that make up the
10% so whatever liquor and the premium
tax don't um equal up to New Hampshire
Health Plan makes a contribution of an
assessment to fill out that
10% the New Hampshire Health Plan um in
in um the prior legislation that was
passed this last session didn't want
that to be an open-ended item and they
said they they would match up to
50% meaning match exactly what both the
liquor and the premium tax equaled and
so that's what's been making up the the
primarily the the uh the non-federal
share there are a couple other um
straggle items like for example if we
were able to recoup some money or on
something that was paid out that also
helps fill that 10% but that's that's Mo
majority of the funding is through those
sources and be happy to it's a lot to
follow I'd be happy to map it out um for
you uh and for the
committee so just to respond to that you
don't need to respond to this but just
so you understand why I still have
questions I'd like like to know what the
N Hampshire plan assessment is but I
don't need to understand that right now
but the really critical part of what I
was reading there
was assessments to no more than the
funding needed to cover the remainder
amount not to exceed the monies from
insurance premium tax revenue and that
become we don't you like I said you
don't need to respond to that now but
that becomes relevant in some of my next
questions in terms of what's what
so essentially it's those sources fill
up the the nonfederal share I think the
remainder amount based on the the
current legislation that passed in hb2
adjusted how that calculation is done a
little bit but at the end of the day the
same concept applies which is we have to
come up with 10% of funding that's not
General funds and it's basically those
sources um liquor tax and the health
plan assessment um the health plan
sometimes assessment is may have known
as the New Hampshire Health Plan
sometimes was known as the high-risk
pool historically they're very important
in the 1332 waiver that the insurance
department has in terms of helping us
with the the individual Market but
that's that's their function today they
have the function of the supporting the
the 1332 waiver through for the
insurance department and they an
assessment on all policies that that
that apply that leads to the funding of
uh granted
Advantage
okay it sounds like you started to
address the significance of the
remainder account and all that that go
for now um that was in my next question
um can you describe the provision this
is another quote the provisions of the
Managed Care contract to protect against
overfunding the Managed Care
organizations is addressed in the risk
settlement mechanism
yes there're um in the environment that
we've been recently operating in where
enrollment shot up because of the
continuous coverage um and uh the the
volatility and healthc care provider uh
capacity that predicting what would be
um the actual spend that we would see we
um you know recommended not only by
actuaries but by CMS was to put in
Provisions to protect from overfunding
the program and um limited um The Profit
potential for the mcos and you know the
way it's worked out um has been that the
state has gotten a refund back of um of
the funding because they didn't
experience um you know utilization that
cost a lot more than what we had actuly
provided
for thank you that one made sense um is
there a document showing the annual
total cost of the state I.E the
non-federal dollars and a detail
breakdown of where that funding is
coming from in law in law over time and
you kind of touched on it in your
earlier response so maybe this one if
you just get it to me in a written form
I really appreciate it sure though we're
required each each quarter to do a
sufficient funding letter to U
leadership um the Senate President the
speaker and and the governor um we're
also required every August to do a
funding um letter it's actually one of
the in our conversation offline it's one
of the letters that I provided to you
that provides the detail in terms of
what is the expenditure um and um what
are the other sources of funding
um let me zo I appreciate that and I
have read the letter and it does make
sense um I guess I'm asking something a
little in a little different format if
you will so when we do our budgeting
like the state budget for Medicaid for
instance right you know you can see the
costs you can see the breakdown of the
revenues Federal General and so on it's
basically Federal in general maybe other
in some cases um in this case what
you're describing
shows costs in you know different ways I
just want to see here's the cost for the
everything um all the little bits and
pieces and here's exactly where the uh
revenues are coming from pretty much as
you were starting to as you describe in
the first part of your answer but just
in know in a nice clean way over time so
we can see how the cost of the program
has changed over time both in terms of
going up but also now that it's coming
down yes and and in the letter you'll
see is that we're expecting it to come
down $100 million um from right you know
the current last fiscal year yep um and
the last one is
um and this relates to a spreadsheet you
sent me that I res shared with you
recently um so if it doesn't make sense
hopefully you can refer to that why
would net nonfederal funds this is my
term not not not in the document why
would net non-federal funds show a
surplus in a given year when hb4 2019
funds transferred exceed that Surplus
amount I.E why is too much money being
transferred so kind of in the bigger
picture standpoint right we make a
forecast of what the program is going to
cost we asked for funding for it you
know the risk card is a good example of
you know if we don't get it perfect
right is to make sure that the money
comes back to support the program in
future years and the the the budget has
had the Medicaid uh U
non-aps because there's been a lot of um
uncertainty in terms of what the the
volume and utilization has been and
that's that I think is what you're
seeing in that chart is that in some
periods um for example we may from the
non-federal share portion or even the
federal share portion expect to get more
than spend more than we we did and so if
we have a surplus of that we just apply
it to the next year to reduce the burden
I don't know if you want to add to to
clarify representative F though the
spreadsheet that you're referring to is
granted Advantage Healthcare program
only so so RSA 126 AA continually it has
there's a trust fund and it's
continually appropriated to the
department so to Henry's point we make
our best estimates if there are
variation there is a surplus and that
would carry forward and that would feed
into the next year's estimates on what
funding would be needed okay so I
understand what you just said y but it
seems like that the way you described it
gives you a motivation to over budget
because you're going to just keep
carrying it forward and building up a
huge Surplus we we don't we don't for
for the granted Advantage Healthcare
program there is no motivation to over
budget um as passed in hb2 this past and
again the funding has changed a little
bit but not significantly um if I could
just provide some context here so like
if I'm these numbers I can validate more
precisely but just broadly like we had a
$1.3 billion budget for State fiscal
year 23 to cover the entire Medicaid
Program and I think like $33 million was
the recruitment of the risk card so it's
a percentage of total spend it's really
not a high amount and a portion of that
33 million is due back to the feds for
their share so you the the you were
talking about one or two% kind of um you
know uh variation from projected and and
that's um I think you would probably
find to be pretty reasonable based on
how health care costs kind of float
around maybe that other chart I asked
about would would help me here because
basically the 2019
HP4 as I understand it is how you top up
to to solve the problem that you are
didn't have enough money going based on
what the law was prior to that point in
time and so you're basically topping it
up to which I get but why would you top
it up more than is needed to just
maintain as opposed to overshoot by $6
million for instance now I realize these
are much smaller numbers in the Medicaid
Program for sure but on a percentage
basis you know $6 million is substantial
as an over overrun if you will so at at
the time we're talking about a a half a
billion almost a $600 million
expenditure for granted Advantage at the
high point of enrollment um and going
forward that top off part that you
talking about hb4 we're projecting in 24
and 25 not to need to to tap into that
provision it's because granted Advantage
enrollment today is back to about 57,000
individuals we were at
97,000 just on on March 31st so the the
whole situation we're getting back to a
more normal period there's still some um
volatility because you're seeing some
people who leave may be the lower Acuity
patients and so I think we're we're
getting to a more stable State and HP4
was really there for you know a
contingency that actually
happened right just one last comment
then um when you use percentages
comparing it to the whole $500 million
program is not fair because we uh pick
up only 10% so really what you want to
be comparing it to is the 10% which is
something on the order and right now
around 56 million and has been as low as
33 million a few years ago and it's
coming back down again
now I was my percentage was based on the
not just the uh both the federal and
non-federal you're right in terms of the
just looking at the the uh state if you
will right and the overages I'm talking
about are the state overages not
anything related to the
federal thank you for your responses
we'd be happy to follow up with
something more concrete so you have
something to take away for future
reference thanks very much represent
Edwards had questions on
312 I do do we want to move 311 or it's
an information oh that's information
thank you um okay yes I do thank you Mr
chair
um first I I want to congratulate uh you
for uh all of the hard work and great
analysis on doing the Medicaid uh
reimbursement rate adjustments um I only
get called when uh people are unhappy
about something in
DHHS but I I I got a call a concern in
September about how the process was
going and then I got a call from the
same person in October who said she's
been working this issue uh on
reimbursement rates in her segment of
the industry for 37 years and this is
the best that she's ever seen uh her
input considered and have the state
respond to so so I think that's all
that's all really great and I just want
to thank you for all of that because the
Committees had ideas on what this thing
would look like back in June J you know
and earlier but you guys really uh
delivered so I want to thank you thank
you um the the for the question relative
to representative ver this is going to
be easy uh because it because we sort of
rehearsed it earlier um under
Medicaid uh are people
authorized uh to uh to Medicaid uh
eligibility if they are in the state in
a nonadjudicated
status claiming that they are an asylum
Seeker are Asylum SE in other words are
Asylum Seekers who have not yet been
adjudicated Medicaid
eligible there there is no eligibility
status for someone who is not legally
authorized to be here I will say that
all states are required if to in an
emergency situation if someone shows up
in an emergency situation to to cover
that cost on a one-time basis but
there's no continued eligibility that
that
exists followup followup okay so I'm I'm
I'm being really clear here because you
you use the term lawful there that
they're they're residing yeah so so I'm
not a lawyer I'm not certainly not an
immigration lawyer so I'm just asking
very
specifically um given that somebody who
is seeking Asylum is in the United
States lawfully until they get
adjudicated three five years later um in
that interim
period they're residing here lawfully
but does that mean they're eligible for
Medicaid typically there's a five-year
waiting period for those that can gain U
Medicaid
Eligibility this past session um
legislature adopted the lawfully
residing for pregnant women and and
their children um which uh shortens the
fiveyear period that will go into effect
January 1 but um other than that you
know this this area of of different
levels of federal legally residing is is
a complex topic which isn't an area of
my expertise uh but you know just in
general um you know the the individuals
that are that are in the program are
people who are you know legally residing
and have gone through a qualification
status and typically a waiting
period thank you Mr chair representative
f for a
question uh thank you Mr chair I would
like to uh reiterate representative
Edwards um words um
uh you've done a great job putting this
all together and I really really
appreciate the time you've taken to help
me understand all that you all that
you've done it's really been very very
helpful and I just have one question and
again you don't need to answer it now
but I'm just curious as to how the rate
increases that we that youve put in
place here will impact the granted
Advantage costs to the state going
forward um the in the informational item
the last two columns um
uh incorporate the federal and
non-federal share that um had to be
taken into account so that the rates in
the program are standed across the
entire portfolio of uh programs in
Medicaid uh Managed Care
Program so the total impact is $33
million is that accurate 34
maybe
thank representative Earth if you turn
to page um three of attachment one um
there are the totals for the other funds
the granted Advantage other funds in uh
column I and in column J there's the
total federal granted advantage and
federal funds right there yeah so when
when you look at um collectively with
this appropriation the 134 million of
General funds that was made via hb2 it
comes out to about 300 million in change
total dollars that will be allocated
towards increasing that some have
already increased Medicaid
rates thank you very much course Senator
Bradley for a question yeah I also want
to follow up on um what representative
Edwards said I think um those of us in
the Senate should give a shout out to
our friends in the house for
establishing the threshold of as I
recall about $134 million in um Medicaid
rate increases you guys did a lot of
really good work um listen to these
folks when it came over to
us um we accepted that number of the
$134 million but um enable the
department to be able to comply with all
the waivers that they have to comply
with the parody issues that they have to
comply with and so this informational
item is the result of that and I think
that along with what Jess said you know
you guys deserve the entire department
deserves a big huge shout out for
pulling this together um yeah there
there were some people that would have
liked a little more um but I think
overall um you've risen to the task and
and
shown um you know the benefit of what
you folks established in your budget
that we accepted in terms of the overall
so
I think everybody deserves to take a bow
but I I just want
to Mr chairman give you and your
committee a shout out and then the work
that you guys did so you made it easy
for us in the Senate thank you Senator
Bradley and you're right it was a
department effort and one of the key
people is sitting behind us uh Christy
Roy who's a director of the rate setting
unit and um you know without her it
would have not gone as well she did a
great job and and as well as other
people in the department so I appreciate
that you recognize that
too this is an unusual moment to hear
all
these compliment to the HHS
so put it on the
newspapers thank you stick it on the
wall thank you anything else on the
information
items before we go to the uh audits I'd
like to confirm a date for next month
November 17th would be the 3D
Friday which is our traditional meeting
and in the morning is there a problem
with that Senator Bradley chair I'm
going to be out of state that weekend I
would actually if we could do it on
Tuesday the 14th whatever time of the
day you find appropriate um we'll have a
lengthy meeting in the finance committee
on 50
bills from till late on the 14th well um
the reason I ask is that um I've been
asked by the Attorney General to file a
LSR dealing with a YDC so I would like
to be able to participate
um in that fiscal meeting so if it's not
possible it's not possible but Wednesday
or Thursday not I am leaving actually on
Wednesday
okay
so anybody else with a problem on the
17th any other any other day that it's
it's not a busy week other than that
14th that we've got the the full finance
committee meeting and and the 17th is a
deadline so there might be people trying
to squeeze other things in but as near
as I
know um if we went to the the second
Friday if that be a problem for the LBA
or the
Departments Thursday is a holiday Friday
10th is a holiday 10th is a
holiday okay about the
nth the 9th the 9th is not a
holiday anybody have a problem with the
night as long as it's in the morning
morning of Thursday the the
9th excuse
me works for you Senator yes yes thank
you very much all
right now you know why I gave you so
many good
shoutouts One hand washes the other but
you deserve them so there you go there
were some other ones we were not quite
agreement on but we'll come to that
later um is there a problem if we do it
on the 9th for the
a
10:00
fiscal Thursday 9
November cancelling 17
what's okay
yeah now we're ready for a very good
audit
yeah
this is a good
morning good morning Mr
chairman and um members of the committee
for the record I'm Christine Young
director of audits for the
LBA we're here to present the
performance audit report for mental
health Workforce
licensing V skids senior manager with
our office with in charge manager on
this audit she will present the
report thank you also joining us in the
back is a design from each of the boards
Who oversee the licensing and
certification of mental health
professionals in the state as well as
the executive director of
oplc who may wish to address the
committee and uh are available for
questions and with that I will turn it
over to V for the presentation
good morning um morning Mr chair members
of the committee uh my name is V skids
uh this morning I'll be presenting the
Mental Health licensing performance
audit uh the purpose of our audit was to
determine whether there were significant
barriers to entry into the Mental Health
Professions imposed by licensing boards
during fiscal year
2022 our audit reviewed initial
licensing requirements for 15 Mental
Health Professions overseen by the
boards of mental health practice I
psychologists licensing for Alcohol and
Other Drug use professionals medicine
and nursing we also reviewed oplc
processes to determine their impact on
initial
licensing our executive summary starts
on page one for most Mental Health
Professions we found New Hampshire's
education pre-licensed practice
supervision and exam requirements
generally aligned with those established
by national professional organizations
and for most most professions we found
New Hampshire's requirements were in the
middle or slightly lower when compared
to other states we
reviewed while we found statutes and
rules did not impose substantial
licensing barriers some board procedures
may have unnecessarily prolonged the
application process and impeded
streamlining for example some boards
required case-by casee review of every
application at a monthly board meeting
regardless of the licensing risk posed
which prolonged the time it took to get
a license
and reviewing all criminal convictions
regardless of how long ago they occurred
or whether they were substantially or
directly related to the profession also
hindered faster
processing additionally mechanisms
implemented by some boards to expedite
licensing for individuals who are
already licensed in another state did
not appear to save time or reduce
documentation
requirements laws passed at the end of
the 2023 legislative session transferred
some of these responsibilities to the op
PLC and could facilitate a more
streamlined approach however rules still
need to be developed for this
process as shown in our recommendation
summary that starts on page three our
report contains 12 observations and
recommendations all five boards and the
oplc concurred with all 12 observations
and six observations may require some
legislative
action our first four observations
address licensed portability portability
is generally defined as the ability for
individuals who are already determined
qualified to practice in one state to
transfer their qualifications to another
state nationally states have been
reviewing their process to facilitate
portability and address Workforce
issues during the audit period New
Hampshire laws required boards to
facilitate license portability by
identifying the states that have equal
or substantially equivalent licensing
requirements it also required boards to
public a list of states with which New
Hampshire had reciprocity agreements or
had entered into multi-state
compacts none of the boards had a
process to identify the states which may
have equal or substantially equivalent
uh requirements and no boards entered
into reciprocity comp reciprocity
agreements during our audit we reviewed
basic licensing requirements for 15
states and compared them to New
Hampshire that information is found in
appendix
D law that became effective at the end
of August 2023 placed the responsibility
of determining what is considered
substantially equivalent under the
purview of the oplc
director state laws also required boards
to identify the states for which they
have established criteria for Lure by
endorsement endorsement is an expedited
process where States consider the
qualifications of an applicant who
already holds a license in another state
to determine whether these
qualifications could be considered
substantially equivalent to their own
board processes intended to expedite
licensing for individuals already
licensed in another state did not
significantly reduce the amount of time
for them to obtain a license for some
professions applicants were still
required to provide most of the same
documents uh as someone who's never been
licensed before and most boards still
required applicants be reviewed on a
case-by casee
basis board laws allowing individuals
already licensed in another state to
practice temporarily while their
application was pending in New Hampshire
was also not aligned with more recent
overarching state law and appeared to be
underutilized overarching state laws
established specific criteria for
obtaining a temporary license however
some boards imposed additional
requirements additionally while
overarching state laws allowed temporary
licenses to be valid valid for up to 120
days time frames in board laws and rules
allowed them to be valid for between 30
and 100 0
days finally state laws required boards
to develop processes to facilitate
portability for members of the military
or military spouses however no boards
have developed these
processes our next two observations
numbers five and six address timeliness
of application processing we found time
limits in some boards rules did not
align with overarching state laws for
certain aspects of the application
process additionally while we found
boards met processing timelines
established in statute most of the time
they could not actually determine
whether they were meeting timelines
because the licensing system did not
collect dates associated with key events
that would have been necessary to
monitor timeliness nor was there a
process to manually collect these dates
to ensure
compliance observations seven and eight
address developing or expanding a tiered
approach to approving license
applications a tiered approach including
approvals at levels below the full board
could have reduced approval time for
some applications presenting low risk
allowing these applicants to practice
sooner two boards required all
applications to be reviewed by a month
at a monthly board meeting even ones
that pose lower risk one board allowed
oplc staff to approve some applications
and issue licenses however other types
of lower risk applications could have
potentially been approved without full
Board review reducing the time for some
applicants to be licensed in July 2023
the oplc became responsible for
approving or denying license
applications facilitating this tiered
approach however oplc is still
developing rules for this
process observation number nine
addresses board practices for reviewing
applicants criminal histories state laws
allowed boards to disqualify applicants
for criminal convictions that had a
substantial or direct relationship to
the profession and if disqual qualifi
the applicant protected Public Safety
however boards did not identify which
convictions were substantially direct
substantially or directly related to
their profession and three boards
required applicants disclose criminal
charges even if they did not result in a
conviction laws also allowed boards to
consider the time passed since the
conviction but none of the board's laws
or rules considered this and applicants
were required to disclose all
convictions regardless of how long ago
the conviction
occurred
observations 10 11 and 12 address the
need to develop rules for some licensing
processes used by the boards ensuring
these requirements are clear and
consistently applied and reviewing
whether exam requirements may be too
restrictive that the delay that they
delay licensing or hinder portability
for applicants who are already licensed
in another
state this concludes my presentation I'd
like to thank take the opportunity take
the opportunity to thank the PLC and
especially the boards for their
cooperation during the audit responding
to all 12 observations in addition to
dealing with their normal course of
business was not an easy feat but the
boards were Cooperative worked hard to
respond to the observations and met our
reporting timeline so we wanted to make
sure the committee was aware of their
hard work um I'd like to invite Lindsay
Courtney up uh she's the oplc D
executive director she has a few
comments we going to have a couple
questions here but you can take a one of
those side seats and be ready to
possibly answer it first Senator Pearl
and then representative Edwards have
questions Senator Pearl is recognized
thank you Mr chair I'm quickly reading
through this as you're providing the
information the the summary that you're
reading is that essentially in here all
of that information it is uh so if you
look at our executive summary most of
the stuff that I said in the very
beginning it comes directly from our
executive summary um so all of that
information is uh on pages one and two
and then the observations go into more
detail I I found the remarks as you
presented them very easy to follow was
it possible that you have a written
version of that you could get to me of
my remarks yes I do however I'm going to
defer to my director as to whether or
not I can release that if I could CER
Pro we'll have a transcript a Verbatim
transcript for this meeting so I can
make sure to get that to the members
that would be excellent thank you
represent Edwards uh thank you Mr chair
I I um this this feels like really very
good work so so thank you for that uh
you've got approximately six
recommendations here that uh you think
may need some legislative action I'd
like to ask you two questions about
those one uh is there one or two of them
that would have the biggest impact on
improving our service capacity in the
state and if so what are they uh I'm
looking for a prioritization of these
six and then sort of attendant with that
is to make sure that we don't drop the
Baton who who is working with who in the
legislature to take legislative action
um so I will address the first part of
that and I will defer the second part to
uh Lindsay Courtney uh to answer so as
far as the observations that require
legislative action there's six of
them none a lot of them are clarifying
some language or um getting rid of uh
negated language that has Su that was
superseded by uh more recent laws so uh
as far as impact I think number 12 may
have the most impact which is uh looking
at the exam requirements for uh marriage
and family therapists and uh clinical
Mental Health Counselors the laws are
very very prescriptive as far as what
national exam a person must pass there
are other exams out there that would um
prevent someone who passed a different
exam from being licensed in New
Hampshire from getting a license so as
far as impact that one probably has the
most impact um and most of the others
are removing some negated language
looking to see um clarifying some laws
to let me back up a little bit uh oplc
was given some authority to oversee
certain processes some of that language
is still in the board's practice act so
making that a little more clear that the
responsibility has been transferred to
oplc and not creating that confusion
between the two uh languages that don't
exactly match um I think that that would
help clarify some certain things but
most of these recommendations are in
that nature so so thank you for drawing
our attention to observation number 12
that's that that's useful your all your
comments are useful and then so for item
12 specifically who in oplc or wherever
is working with which legislature
legislator to to implement 12 I think I
can answer that question
partly the Prof the uh this division
works for the fiscal committee when they
bring an audit to us we're the first
people that see it no one else has seen
it until we've clear it and publish it I
always take the action that we are
responsible for anything that comes to
us needing legislative change I usually
file it myself I'm going to have to go
to rules committee to ensure that we can
get this in in a timely way since both
the Senate and the house um have passed
the deadlines for final legislation I
will go to rules and I will ask to for
permission to file the bill and then I
will ask for
um for the different six different ones
who might be the liaison obviously
they're different boards and so on and
so I can take this I admire the work you
always do excellent work thank you this
was very timely as we're hearing from
HHS the problem in Staffing all these
positions and you did some wonderful
work where you when I take it to OS you
even mention the law that needs to be
changed they're going to appreciate that
it's going to make it much quicker also
the work you've done for the boards in
appendix D which you found they'd never
done this before should hopefully
expedite when someone comes from another
state all they've got to do is look at
appendix D and you know if it's all if
it's all green and yellow boom don't
waste a lot of time we we did only look
at 15 states so there are other states
and we've talked to the boards about how
to prioritize looking at other States as
well it's an excellent start Senator
rosenell thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to say that I have filed a bill
that's not
unrelated which could be a vehicle for
these
statuto are you willing to to put all
these on it yes I have already texted
director Courtney asking if we could
chat after this
meeting so I guess what would be
required if we if we saw a liaison for
each of the six ones because there quite
often involved different boards so when
we and I would like to be a co-sponsor
with you oh
yes because I take very seriously when
this audit division comes before us and
said you need Law changes you're talking
to me that's my I want to put you on my
spreadsheet and so you know thank you I
don't want them to spend a Year's work
and then have every but just
say and not do a thing this is an
important method for us to correct our
legislation sen thank thank you Mr
chairman Mr chairman both ncsl and CSG
have spent a lot of effort working on
reciprocity and working on boards it uh
it seems to me that that that work has
already been prated it could really be
uh used quite effectively in terms of
what legislative changes we need and how
more of a synergistic relationship could
be established because one of the
problems that we face is is the Dilemma
of
nonreciprocity for a person coming
coming from from our state from another
state and that's a barrier that that uh
we've got to overcome because you need
we need a fluid situation here and the
national organizations have worked hard
to try to get that done just a C thank
you and Senator delandro the first four
observations in our report actually
address portability and trying to create
a better process for people coming from
other
States Senator f for a
motion uh move to accept place on file
and
release sorry move to accept place on
filing release to the public in the
usual manner second second by senator
greay further
discussion opposed you
said yes she's been trying to get our
attention lady at the end of the
director of OPC let let me make this
accept this motion then I'll recognize
you all in favor say I oppose
no thank you Mr chair members of the
committee um representative Edwards so
I'm I I know you're trying to get out of
here and I appreciate the hard work I
just just wanted to say that um that
thank you to the LBA for the
collaborative environment in which we
worked on these issues and to the boards
um but really as you'll see there are
two issues that were really identified
as it relates to oplc one is the current
conflicts in the law happy to report
that um we have been working with
representative McGuire and
representative groda out of Edna um and
she is um has has has plans to um uh
file legislation um that would uh
eliminate a lot of these conflicts so I
I think that's already in the works we
drafted the language was about 120 pages
so when you see it um I apologize in
advance um the second issue really
concerns portability and I'm and this
audit was particularly challenging
because of all of the changes during the
last legislative session and I just want
to thank uh members of the general court
for all of the hard work that you did
because I think HB 594 in particular was
really critical to moving the ball
forward as it relates to portability so
that was the legislation that
essentially gave the office to uh the
authority to determine what states are
substantially similar or what criteria
is substantially similar that work is
already um being done um the interum
rules that the office filed uh related
to um 15 professions I believe but
included all of the Mental Health
Professions and were effective
on Sunday and um through these new rules
we were able to already get through
hundreds of applications not necessarily
in the Mental Health Professions but
particularly for Physicians um so I
think a lot of this work is underway and
what we're looking at is really just a
cleanup effort as it relates to the
statutory Authority I just wanted to
mention two things for consideration as
it relates to the exam and number 12 um
I think that requires a little bit more
inquiry because I think
um there could be some consequences as
it relates to portability it were the
state to accept other
examinations um the state is currently a
part participating state in the Mental
Health compact I the New Hampshire
representative on that compact
commission and part of the requirements
to participate in the compact is that
you um require a national exam so I'm
not saying that the other exams wouldn't
necessarily qualify um because the
commission is currently promulgating
rules as it relates to the exam but
there could be unintended consequences
and so we may want to look into that a
little bit um deeper before pursuing
additional legislation and as of right
now I believe over 40 states have signed
on to the Mental Health
compact thank you for your thank you for
your time and we just keep piling stuff
on you for licensing and it's awesome
it's great we're doing great work so
thank you to the board and to the staff
no it's it's been wonderful well you
have streamlined things in men ly and
and we appreciate it but it kind of
loads it up in your
office so keep up to good work thank you
Mr chair all right Senator
Pearl thank you so director as as we you
brought up compacts and it was actually
going to be a question I was going to
ask you as as we move forward and we
start to adopt these compacts do you
think that is going to ease up some of
the need for reciprocity and Licensing
because some of the folks that are
coming here maybe licens in other states
and they can do so under the compact
rather than needing to come under the
reciprocity yes so yes Senator so there
essentially are two compact models
there's the multi-state compact model
which is what uh nursing has which
basically means if you get a license in
your home state you can go anywhere
that's part of the compact that is the
best in terms of portability there is
risk there because you don't know who's
in your state and so um when we talk
about Mental Health Professions in
particular where they're not necessarily
always working in an environment where
there's supervision certain professions
have chosen a different model which is a
privilege to practice which is that you
still have to come to each state and get
a privilege based on streamlined
requirements the benefit to a compact is
always that you can share data there's a
requirement that you share data so as it
relates to investigations and discipline
we know more about that person if we're
part of the compact than we don't but I
view it as really concurrent models that
you could use there are some states that
are never going to participate in a
compact for various reasons um and that
doesn't mean though that they don't have
similar requirements and so really um I
think the state should be looking at um
all options for portability um you
mentioned um Senator dallesandro that
CSG and DOD have been working on this um
I've I've had the privilege of working
and drafting the social work compact
language um with CSG and it's really
intended to help support our military
families and to make it easier so um I
think there's a lot of work that we can
um piggy back on and Implement in New
Hampshire thank you anything further
from the committee
members and I'm sure that Senator
rosemal would appreciate any of the rest
of us being co-sponsors on the bill
since it's she's taking the lead on on
doing all this and thank you for all the
good work you've done it should make it
easier for OS and and hopefully we don't
we'll talk to
represent Maguire as well and maybe get
her in on it so we can see that we don't
have any conflicts and stuff she's she's
filed is there anything else to come
before
us
okay I will entertain a motion to
adjourn all in
favor we are adjourned
until we said November
10th 9th November 9th November 9th 9 at
10: a.m. thank
you
agree all right thank you very much I
don't know what the underlying bill that
she was going to put in and said so
there's one you don't know what
underlying Bill you're right but as long
as she inludes this
St I'll have to I'll have to look it
over and then dis yes sir yes sir
yep all
right all right
thank I was
impressed